but just as we need change we know you
want stability and certainty to you need
to know that we won't be a government
that just kicks over the traces for the
sake of it and we won't we won't just
rip everything up and just start again
let me give you an example will improve
local enterprise partnerships rather
than instigating another disruptive
top-down reorganization you need
certainty about tax as well so you know
Britain will be continued to be
competitive come what may that's why we
pledged to keep corporation tax at the
lowest rate in the g7 and for people
like Paul and Margaret we will cut and
freeze business rates for smaller firms
because we think that is the priority
for business tax you need certainty
about infrastructure so you know you'll
have the support the infrastructure
there for you to succeed that's why
we'll follow the recommendation of sir
john armitt and set up a new national
independent infrastructure commission to
break the cycle of dither and delay
that's left our country creaking trying
to run a 21st century economy on 20th
century foundations now this is a plan
for our long-term future a better plan
for British business to invest and to
build for the future let me be clear
about one other thing our long-term
future lies inside not outside the
European Union